did you know that the spelling bee was
invented in the united states
yeah that's not a flex spelling bees are
kind of pointless outside english
because most other languages have
spelling systems that are regular and
predictable but english spelling is such
a mess that just being able to do it
correctly can earn you a trophy these
two words rhyme
but these two don't
these two words rhyme
these two don't
these two rhyme
but these two don't in fact none of
these words rhyme with any of the others
english is full of these contradictions
making it one of the hardest languages
to learn almost every spelling rule
comes with a long list of exceptions i
before e except after c
yeah well what about these uh weird huh
an e at the end of the word supposedly
makes the vowel long like in home and
hive and hate
well i'd love for someone to give me an
explanation for these
many letters can have multiple sounds
and others seem to serve no purpose
whatsoever a k in knife an h in ghost an
s in island
in fact almost every letter of the
alphabet is silent somewhere yeah i got
the receipts some have accused english
spelling of being irrational and
arbitrary but actually
there are good reasons why our spellings
are so strange well
some good reasons some snobby reasons
and some that are downright dumb
i'm dr erica brazovsky and this is other
words
other words
english's wacky spelling goes all the
way back to the origin of the alphabet
old english was a germanic language
spoken by anglo-saxons who used a runic
alphabet known as the futhork as latin
missionaries christianized england
during the 7th century they replaced the
futhoric with the latin alphabet the
thing is the latin alphabet was not
designed for a germanic tongue there
were sounds that anglo-saxons used that
had no equivalent in latin
this required some improvisations some
letters had to do double duty like c
which should work
as in machion
[Music]
and a couple runic letters were kept
around like win which signified the wha
sound and thorn which made the f sound
as you can see the english alphabet had
barely begun and it was already getting
a bit confusing but plenty of other
non-latin languages use the same
alphabet like german dutch and czech and
their spellings while not exactly easy
are at least consistent so how did
english spelling get so uniquely screwed
up
in 1066 william the conqueror invaded
england from normandy and installed
french-speaking nobles to rule it not
only did they bring a ton of french
words with them but the norman scribes
changed the spelling of a lot of english
words to look more familiar to french
readers one of the first things they did
was get rid of those pesky runic letters
they replaced the thorn with th and the
win with two u's which eventually became
what do you know w in french the oo
sound was spelled o u as in crouton and
rouge so old english words like hoos and
hund had o's added the french used gh to
signify the
sound so the old english words nicht and
micht had g's added by the time the
norms were done tinkering with it the
middle english spelling system was
already a jumble of germanic latin and
french conventions but two big events in
linguistic history were about to make
things much much worse
between 1400 and 1700 the pronunciations
of many english vowels shifted no one
knows exactly why this happened but it's
essentially what created the modern
english sounds we used today for
instance the oo sound became ow so hoos
and hun became house and hound
ah became a so name became nema
e became i so lika became laika a lot of
words lost their second syllables all
together so nema and laika became name
and like we still commemorate that
second syllable with the silent e other
consonant sounds faded away as well
dumb became dumb
night in light became night and light
canife and connect became knife and
night you might be thinking if you're
not going to pronounce the sounds
anymore why not get rid of the extra
letters
well some scholars at the time did want
to update the spelling system to match
the new pronunciations but something was
happening concurrently they would lock
in those outdated spellings permanently
around 1440 johannes gutenberg invented
the printing press in germany and within
a hundred years it had spread all across
europe in england this meant that
spellings had to become standardized
right at the time that pronunciations
were shifting moreover the people who
did the standardizing didn't always have
the best reasons dutch typesetters
changed some spellings to match their
flemish conventions like adding an h to
ghost and ghastly and since dumb ended
with a b
some printers mistakenly added b's to
limb crumb and numb an error known as
hypercorrection there was also a lot of
snobbery going on by now the renaissance
was in full swing and scholars were
importing tons of fancy words from greek
latin and french with their fancy
spellings these were derogatorily known
as inkhorn words named for the ink pots
that nerds and know-it-alls kept on
their desks as if that wasn't bad enough
the renaissance fanboys also wanted to
change the spellings of existing english
words to pay tribute to their
etymological roots
words of greek descent were signified by
adding an h after the c as in chronicle
and chaos and substituting ph for f as
in physics phlegm and pharmacy and words
of latin origin like debt doubt sign
receipt indict and aisle had letters
added not to be pronounced but just as a
reminder to readers where those words
originally came from
in another instance of hyper correction
they even added an s to the word island
mistakenly believing it was related to
the word isle in fact the two words have
totally different origins
classic case of over nerding the end of
the great vowel shift represents the
beginning of modern english but thanks
to the printing press it was stuck with
a spelling system that was based on
germanic roots with a latin script using
french spellings to describe middle
english pronunciations
some have attempted to modernize english
spelling most notably noah webster who
in the early 1800s suggested a bunch of
phonetically corrected changes
some stuck
others did not
this list kind of reminds me of the
recent trend in phonetic spelling
popularized by texting and social media
though it's typically employed for humor
and brevity it does speak to an
underlying desire for a written language
to more closely match our spoken one
while it may seem far-fetched that
dictionaries would ever make these
things official
stranger things have happened until then
we can at least take comfort in knowing
that our spelling quirks are evidence of
a language that is uniquely flexible
absorbent and multicultural
and that we live in the age of spell
check i take great comfort and spell
check
night
and locked
more phlegm
knocked knight and liked
night and
i can't night connect
i never have to say night again